donc nourri au fc un tribunal judiciaire
à l'arrivée et tenant compte de sa
grippe on pourrait déterminer où un
changement de stratégie ou une
adaptation de travail constitués en
comité de défense de leurs droits
la résidence de la cité grenade à tous
pas bouillon débute aujourd'hui une
nouvelle action sous forme de rencontres
avec la population
il souhaite obtenir le désamiantage de
leur résidence principale mais aussi
leurs titres de propriété
on a des gens qui depuis 30 ans vivent
dans une situation inhumaine en présence
d'amiante et il est anormal que le maire
qui est responsable de la santé de ses
habitants ne fasse rien que la le préfet
qui a été saisie le sous-préfet a été
saisie ne prennent aucune initiative que
le directeur de l'ars agence régionale
de santé qui responsables de la santé ne
fasse rien
et dire qu'on est dans une situation
absolument anormal il n'y en action
judiciaire mais si les y est opaque a
mobilisé causses ou pas tu as fait et on
entend une voix et mécénat comprendre
que yo préféré annuler sur des années
des années ça tout ça il aurait répandu
des plats
ce retraité occultes au logement depuis
près de 30 ans il a refait sa toiture
amiantée à cause des infiltrations d'eau
mais aujourd'hui il ne peut bénéficier
d'aucune aide pour poursuivre les
travaux soient déjà oublié des monts
finition des conneries là à quel moment
dans l'autre crédit au moins pp toi tu
la matière
au fond c'est qu'il y ait des gares ou
les finir mais karl et et docks amiens
en 1987
quarante familles si le contrat de
location vente de logements sociaux leur
permettons bout d'une quinzaine d'années
de devenir propriétaire selon le maire
de la commune
si certains ont pu honorer leur contrat
d'autres ne sont toujours pas à jour ce
qui complique la situation
on a fait tout ce qu'il y avait à fait
que l'époux fiscaux cdu devait les
mettre en place on les appelait les
prospections sur les maisons qui
aggravent on a délégué une entreprise
tout ça c'est fait et on attend de
savoir si effectivement la
réhabilitation des voies effectivement
vu soutenu les communes l'atelier aussi
les propriétaires nous verrons comment
est-ce que les choses vont finir il est
certain que le danger est bien présent
dans ce logement à cause de l'amiante
dans l'attenté d'une décision de justice
le comité annonce de nouvelles
mobilisations